today's video is sponsored by surf shark
and vpn an all boys nipple team is
allowed to compete against an all girls
team for the state title now the all
boys team wins every match running up
huge score lines including a 30 goal
victory in the grand final all the while
parents watch on they're angry but
they're powerless from the sidelines now
it all sounds like a fixture does it a
hollywood movie that's exactly what
happened at the queensland netball
titles earlier this week with an
all-male queensland sons blitzed their
all-female competitors to be crowned the
queensland under 18 state champions men
who in their right mind thought this was
okay
what i'd like to say is that when nepal
australia says this is all about
inclusion what who's being included here
because it's certainly not the women and
girls everybody's being included who's
playing boys and girls we're included
doesn't mean you're going to win but
you're included isn't that what we
wanted but here's the thing sports isn't
about winning it's about participation
yeah yeah and you participated so you
participated in the hell
that's what he did
participate in the big one yeah you know
what happened big help they changed the
rules to allow males to be able to play
with the women and this team were just
picking men
steamrolled everybody in their first
year sorry if i'm enjoying this too much
oh yeah you you is this something about
equal opportunity
yeah um they're being excluded uh
they're being expected to yet again
sacrifice their sports to make sure that
men and boys feel included
no when we watch women's sports we want
to see the best women and girls that the
world has to offer we don't want to see
men and boys taking up space on the on
the netball court no no
you can't look this happy dominating
with him no no no
[Music]
i thought dunking was the best sensation
but dunking on women is better
and they're not going to boast about it
after that
but if it's me i'm making that all my
profile picture
i'm creating accounts just to make it my
profile picture i'm downloading
bumbleton i don't care if i'm married or
not
that's my only picture
and i'm not even gonna put my real name
on put winner winner chicken dinner
that's gonna be my username on every
platform that is
winner winner chicken dinner winner i
want a medal and on the medal it's just
a male dunking on a woman and she's like
with an apron on
she got an apron i'm just dunking
i would go to the extreme if it's me
today's video is sponsored by surf shark
vpn a vpn is just
an application or a web extension that
you could use on your internet browser
to mask your ip address to change the
location of your ip you might be like yo
but i like where i live the block is hot
what happens when you want to watch a tv
show and it says we don't offer it to
people in your country what you going to
do who are you going to call not
ghostbusters right i was trying to watch
a tv show in the uk so i was like hey
man let me in and they said no no nobody
from canada so i changed my ipad address
using surfsharkvpn
all of a sudden bruff i'm from brixton
wagon and now if you sign up with the
promo code abba and preach you get 83
off for the next four months because
it's black friday deals and i'm a black
man so i got y'all some extra special
we stand by the decision to choose
inclusion over exclusion let's judge the
decision in 12 months time and say how
many boys and men's team we have
because if we can't you can't be it
if you go sorry you can't see it if you
can't be it now
what did that even
mean what did you
if you can't smell what's happening in
the kitchen you can't go to it huh the
[ __ ] happened there
listen i think it's fine for people to
swim in the water with the sharks why
because if the fins are visible
boy you might be invisible i was like
huh you're asking me you're asking you
actually preach hooked on findings
you can't be it
oh okay i think i understood right now
basically she's saying is if we don't
get these young men and boys to
participate people who don't see that
won't be able to participate in the
sport because they can't imagine
themselves in those roles so this is a
matter of representation what they want
to do is have more male dominance
represented in sports to encourage more
young boys to continue dominating these
sports and not letting women get any
shine
but that doesn't make any sense still
it does it's representation it's like if
you put our representation of boys
representation of women no no they're
trying to do the representation of boys
in netball
why because they want to give us another
dub why are you complaining can you just
shut the [ __ ] up and let men win again
or on the podium and frankly i'd like to
say to these boys they should have
forfeited i mean if they wanted to play
netball they should have done what women
and girls have always historically done
over the years and decades and centuries
of fighting for equality
for access to sporting opportunities and
we've gotten out there we've done the
recruiting we've done the fundraising
we've built our own leagues and here you
have these boys going i want to be
included so i'm just going to jump on in
with the women and i don't care about
their right to fair competition don't
care about their right to safety
i'm just going to play why are you
talking [ __ ] about these guys these guys
are just going to come here win the
prize and get their money i'm not going
to be mad at men for taking the
opportunity to get the bread that they
want you should be mad at the women who
made this optional and made this a rule
the president of this thing is a female
she's the one who's talking about
inclusion and making this important and
yet you're blaming young men for this
change no no no no no
hold the accountability for the l that
you gave these women don't blame it on
the dudes that's your problem she tried
to say these young men should have four
excuse me you made it a rule you don't
put a check in front of somebody and get
mad when they grab it if you open the
opportunity for them to grab it that's
on you so yet again we're seeing um male
entitlement um a lovely example of it
here from netball australia male
entitlement oh my days
all my days
oh my days you can just see women get on
a skateboard fall off scrape their knee
and be like male entitlement
no no no no no no we're not doing this
today
we
are not doing this today male
entitlement yeah male 1 tournament
mel entitlement who raised you
but there's them
it's really that it's really it's melody
yeah we're entitled why do we play it's
not because they made it a rule abba
that we had to go there and destroy
everybody we were entitled the rule was
fair well the rule was what it was and
they put the rule up but we didn't have
to abide by the rule knowing that it was
unfair that's just unfair male
entitlement
it's a female that made the rule but
it's male entitlement ah
yeah a feminist who's in charge you said
you wanted women in charge you put a
woman in charge she makes rules that you
don't like and you still blame the
patriarch that's [ __ ]
insane that's crazy it's not crazy
that's crazy that's crazy that's crazy
that's crazy it's what they do that's
crazy it's what they do it's like this
woman's allergic to accountability
you
made the rules
you did this for inclusion we
participated what you asked for then you
blame us yeah
yeah
yeah male entitlement
huh it's yeah
yeah man let's ultimate bro listen this
it is what it is listen why did we
participate in that we should have known
better it was for us to make the steps
not to be in that predicament knowing
that it wasn't fair even if they made
the rule
so we went by the rules but it was
unfair because we went there so it's our
male entitlement
ha
our fault the boy should have never done
it
foster them you know what this makes me
think of it's like the guys who
go out there and like fund these only
fans women and then pays for their
instagram feeds and all that stuff and
then afterwards calls them horse yeah
it's like [ __ ] you you financed it the
[ __ ] is you talking about bro yeah yeah
you out here talking about oh these are
nothing but [ __ ] and [ __ ] you're out
here paying for it and then you get
insulted about it afterwards and getting
upset
part of the system
like those people that said i'm stuck in
traffic no you're traffic you're the
traffic yeah you're you're you're that
yeah yeah and the dudes being happy you
know what
i think
i think i appreciate what they did even
more now you wanna know why why because
they're exposing the stupidity of these
people
oh you want guys to come play because
you think that's inclusion okay okay so
shout out to the netball team the male
netball team out there in australia
you've done a wonderful job for the rest
of the world we appreciate you guys and
for the ladies who blame the patriarchy
okay will you keep doing that and see
what happens to your sports because hell
no am i going to come out here and say
this shit's unfair you asked for it now
you can enjoy it
big hell prison peace